you know I'm pretty sure this is the
only t shirt I wear with this suit why
because it's a t-shirt that says
everybody lies on it why would I not
wear that so yes folks it is that time
of year again we're talking award season
I'm not talking the Oscars although the
Oscars are right around the corner but
what else is right around the corner is
a third annual you reviewers movie award
somebody right now we're like what the
hell are the you reviewers Movie Awards
I get you I've got a lot of new faces
this past year so let me explain it
briefly a couple years ago the Oscar
nominations came out everyone was like
these are terrible I was one of those
people then Christian from schmoes know
called me up and he was like dude let's
do our own movie awards show it'll be
awesome it'll be fun so like oh yeah
that sounds like fun so we did it in the
next year we had the second annual you
reviewers movie awards this year the
third annual you reviewers movie awards
God willing life is awesome it's not
going anywhere we'll always have them
and the nominees and winners are voted
on by movie reviewers on YouTube and the
winners of these categories are
presented by your favorite movie
reviewers on YouTube hopefully your
favorite movie reviewers on YouTube and
the entire thing is hosted by myself and
Christian and mark from schmoes now
almost like an award show but less snob
eNOS tell me does it sound like a party
cuz it totally is and this is why I love
the you reviewers Movie Awards this is
how I see it we live in the digital age
of information which is given the people
just normal people out there a voice the
likes of which they've never had in the
history of the earth the you reviewers
movie award celebrates that fact you
know normal people who are like I have a
hobby for movies I'm a total cinephile
let's have our own thing is people like
you doing it which goes into the other
fact which is people who review movies
on YouTube they're just normal people
like you dude now this year is pretty
cool for you guys because i'm happy to
say the year reviewers movie awards is
coming home but i mean by that is last
year a studio was like hey will film the
show will edit it will host it as
thankful as we were for that and we
still are thankful to them for that but
the schmoes and i feel that the you
reviewers movie awards will be best
represented if it comes home on our
channel so it'll be broken up into four
parts this time as always part 1 will be
on my channel part 2 on schmoes know
channel 3 on my channel 4 on the schmoes
know channel and we'll give you guys a
fun little award show why because you
got to have fun and what you do and this
is what we do for not having fun doing
it what's the point of doing it this
year in la all filming together schmoes
know we'll be there Kathryn reitman will
be there I will be there chris stuckmann
will be there flick pickle be there play
a little conglom
nation of youtubers the town's not ready
for this yeah la has seen some but
it's not ready for this let the rum and
cokes and fireball shots flow my friends
and this is what I really loved in the
past week a lot of people have made you
reviewers movie awards videos you know
they're talking about it they're getting
jacked up couple people have made
trailers for it I love seeing that kind
of stuff I love seeing that what we do
gets people excited then people getting
excited gets us excited I have a
symbiotic thing happening here my
friends like Eddie Brock and Venom
symbiote not really he's a good guy
though more or less so I guess so and
we're planning on having the you
reviewers movie awards about a week
before the Oscars so middle of februari
check back here subscribe to the schmoes
and telling you the fun of award shows
in the palm of your hand or at least
your computer monitor or the palm of
your hand if you're using a phone so
we're always taking suggestions so what
did you like about the last couple years
Movie Awards what didn't you like aa
mint below let me know and as always if
you like what you seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more